hallo keck wait warum gibt es eigentlich nicht hock wait moment ich muss mal
kurz meine e-mails schenkt hock wait gibt es garantiert auch wie die idee ist
noch keiner gekommen und seriously keiner der bisher auch
great als die mode gibt keinen gibt keinen stream zu gucken
zendrix danke für den sub subscriptions ja heute funktioniert
twitch auch wieder ich sehe seine zuschauer zahlen nach einer minute geht
direkt hoch nicht wie letztens irgendwie 20 minuten bis der stream richtig
funktioniert hat ich weiß nicht was wir heute machen leute ich bin ehrlich
gesagt nur angekommen damit ich bisschen was zu tun habe ich habe nichts geplant
und ich habe nichts vor ich könnte mmo kreiselcoin machen habe ich aber
nicht vor ich könnte mmo kreiselcoin machen habe ich aber nicht vor ich könnte mmo kreiselcoin machen habe ich aber
heute schon den halben tag über und deswegen dachte ich mich mach mal
einfach streamern ohne irgendwie großartigen plan
theoretisch besser name danke für den sub
theoretisch besser name danke für den sub iq barf abgeholt exzellenz krupp krupp
iq barf abgeholt exzellenz krupp krupp
iq barf abgeholt exzellenz krupp krupp krupp barf ich trinke schon was sehr gut
barf ich trinke schon was sehr gut
barf ich trinke schon was sehr gut zweite urlaubstag direkt ich habe kein
zweite urlaubstag direkt ich habe kein
zweite urlaubstag direkt ich habe kein langweilig potato bob kein sub so finde
langweilig potato bob kein sub so finde
langweilig potato bob kein sub so finde ich das gut vielleicht können auch mehr
ich das gut vielleicht können auch mehr
ich das gut vielleicht können auch mehr leute nicht subscriben
leute nicht subscriben
leute nicht subscriben wisst ihr was wir gerade einfällt ich
wisst ihr was wir gerade einfällt ich
wisst ihr was wir gerade einfällt ich weiß ich weiß wirklich nicht wie ich da
weiß ich weiß wirklich nicht wie ich da
weiß ich weiß wirklich nicht wie ich da gerade drauf komme es ist es ist
gerade drauf komme es ist es ist
gerade drauf komme es ist es komplett es ist komplett random gebe ich zu das mit
komplett es ist komplett random gebe ich zu das mit
komplett es ist komplett random gebe ich zu das mit so zu anstrengend
so zu anstrengend
so zu anstrengend ja lieber wieder die hier die playlist
ja lieber wieder die hier die playlist
ja lieber wieder die hier die playlist auch nicht verkehrt
auch nicht verkehrt
auch nicht verkehrt also auch noch ein giftet der captain
also auch noch ein giftet der captain
also auch noch ein giftet der captain porgas hat 1 gekriegt für die gift ja
porgas hat 1 gekriegt für die gift ja
porgas hat 1 gekriegt für die gift ja aber wisst ihr was mir gerade ich bin
aber wisst ihr was mir gerade ich bin
aber wisst ihr was mir gerade ich bin echt unschlüssig wie ich gerade drauf
echt unschlüssig wie ich gerade drauf
echt unschlüssig wie ich gerade drauf gekommen bin was er zumindest ist mir
gekommen bin was er zumindest ist mir
gekommen bin was er zumindest ist mir gerade eingefallen dass in offenbach
gerade eingefallen dass in offenbach
gerade eingefallen dass in offenbach jemand rumläuft
jemand rumläuft
jemand rumläuft als scheißhaufen verkleidet um darauf
als scheißhaufen verkleidet um darauf
als scheißhaufen verkleidet um darauf aufmerksam zu machen dass es eine blöde
aufmerksam zu machen dass es eine blöde
aufmerksam zu machen dass es eine blöde idee ist wenn die hundebesitzer ihre
idee ist wenn die hundebesitzer ihre
idee ist wenn die hundebesitzer ihre hunde auf den gehweg scheißen lassen
hunde auf den gehweg scheißen lassen
hunde auf den gehweg scheißen lassen keine ahnung wie ich drauf komme aber
keine ahnung wie ich drauf komme aber
keine ahnung wie ich drauf komme aber irgendwie ist mir das gerade wieder
irgendwie ist mir das gerade wieder
irgendwie ist mir das gerade wieder eingefallen dass es in offenbach so eine
eingefallen dass es in offenbach so eine
eingefallen dass es in offenbach so eine werbeaktion also wer das nicht gesehen
werbeaktion also wer das nicht gesehen
werbeaktion also wer das nicht gesehen hat das ist schon ein paar monate her ich
hat das ist schon ein paar monate her ich
hat das ist schon ein paar monate her ich weiß nicht warum ihr ausgerechnet das
weiß nicht warum ihr ausgerechnet das
weiß nicht warum ihr ausgerechnet das jetzt einfällt aber offenbach soll ich
jetzt einfällt aber offenbach soll ich
jetzt einfällt aber offenbach soll ich nach scheißhaufen suchen auch wie das ist
nach scheißhaufen suchen auch wie das ist
nach scheißhaufen suchen auch wie das ist weg city ist weg auch hier guckt mal so
weg city ist weg auch hier guckt mal so
weg city ist weg auch hier guckt mal so sagt die ursprünglich auch hallo
sagt die ursprünglich auch hallo
sagt die ursprünglich auch hallo telekom das ist so naja das habe ich
telekom das ist so naja das habe ich
telekom das ist so naja das habe ich offenbach in offenbach probiert ob es
offenbach in offenbach probiert ob es
offenbach in offenbach probiert ob es funktioniert hat aber anscheinend
funktioniert hat aber anscheinend
funktioniert hat aber anscheinend anscheinend wurde shitty abgesetzt aus
anscheinend wurde shitty abgesetzt aus
anscheinend wurde shitty abgesetzt aus für city in offenbach mag aller ende
für city in offenbach mag aller ende
für city in offenbach mag aller ende mai hat offenbach dann wandelt noch
mai hat offenbach dann wandelt noch
mai hat offenbach dann wandelt noch unten auf die stadtpartei tatsächlich
unten auf die stadtpartei tatsächlich
unten auf die stadtpartei tatsächlich aber kamen city nie zum einsatz der
aber kamen city nie zum einsatz der
aber kamen city nie zum einsatz der grund zu viel auf moment moment
grund zu viel auf moment moment
grund zu viel auf moment moment wollen die nicht gerade damit
wollen die nicht gerade damit
wollen die nicht gerade damit aufmerksamkeit wie kann es dazu viel
aufmerksamkeit wie kann es dazu viel
aufmerksamkeit wie kann es dazu viel aufmerksamkeit geben
aufmerksamkeit geben
aufmerksamkeit geben er schallt massive subskription ich
er schallt massive subskription ich
er schallt massive subskription ich wollte hier oben was zu sagen hast du
wollte hier oben was zu sagen hast du
wollte hier oben was zu sagen hast du eigentlich eine endlötstation habe ich
eigentlich eine endlötstation habe ich
eigentlich eine endlötstation habe ich nicht wie soll sowas aussehen du meinst
nicht wie soll sowas aussehen du meinst
nicht wie soll sowas aussehen du meinst sicherlich nicht heißluft oder du
sicherlich nicht heißluft oder du
sicherlich nicht heißluft oder du meinst du meinst sowas zum zum absaugen
meinst du meinst sowas zum zum absaugen
meinst du meinst sowas zum zum absaugen oder sowas also ich hab da ich hab da
oder sowas also ich hab da ich hab da
oder sowas also ich hab da ich hab da zwei sachen die funktion aber nur semi
zwei sachen die funktion aber nur semi
zwei sachen die funktion aber nur semi gut ich habe einmal so ein ding was
gut ich habe einmal so ein ding was
gut ich habe einmal so ein ding was kurz unterdruck erzeugt und so das lötzinn
kurz unterdruck erzeugt und so das lötzinn
kurz unterdruck erzeugt und so das lötzinn weg saugen kann das ist aber naja
weg saugen kann das ist aber naja
weg saugen kann das ist aber naja und dann habe ich ein bisschen kupfer
und dann habe ich ein bisschen kupfer
und dann habe ich ein bisschen kupfer drahtgeflecht was man drauf drücken kann
drahtgeflecht was man drauf drücken kann
drahtgeflecht was man drauf drücken kann und dann den lötkolben dran machen und
und dann den lötkolben dran machen und
und dann den lötkolben dran machen und dann saugt sich das so das kupfer rein
dann saugt sich das so das kupfer rein
dann saugt sich das so das kupfer rein die ist jetzt aber auch nicht das
die ist jetzt aber auch nicht das
die ist jetzt aber auch nicht das allergeilste ja also entlöten wenn was
allergeilste ja also entlöten wenn was
allergeilste ja also entlöten wenn was richtig fällt mir schwer was ich mal
richtig fällt mir schwer was ich mal
richtig fällt mir schwer was ich mal gemacht habe es war richtig pepega ich
gemacht habe es war richtig pepega ich
gemacht habe es war richtig pepega ich hab mal auf dem raspberry pi 0w und auf
hab mal auf dem raspberry pi 0w und auf
hab mal auf dem raspberry pi 0w und auf so ein ohr noch ich habe die gps auf
so ein ohr noch ich habe die gps auf
so ein ohr noch ich habe die gps auf die falsche seite gelötet die gps die
die gps die gps die gps die gps die habe ich nach unten gelötet was dummes
habe ich nach unten gelötet was dummes
habe ich nach unten gelötet was dummes was da kann man nix mehr richtig
was da kann man nix mehr richtig
was da kann man nix mehr richtig draufstecken und dann wollte ich das
draufstecken und dann wollte ich das
draufstecken und dann wollte ich das ganze wieder ablöten
ganze wieder ablöten
ganze wieder ablöten das war in der tat nicht so einfach wie
das war in der tat nicht so einfach wie
das war in der tat nicht so einfach wie gedacht weil wenn ihr euch vorstellt in
gedacht weil wenn ihr euch vorstellt in
gedacht weil wenn ihr euch vorstellt in jedem dieser löcher als er kommt also
jedem dieser löcher als er kommt also
jedem dieser löcher als er kommt also ein peter rein in jedem dieser löcher
ein peter rein in jedem dieser löcher
ein peter rein in jedem dieser löcher ist lötzinn wenn du das hier ablötet auf
ist lötzinn wenn du das hier ablötet auf
ist lötzinn wenn du das hier ablötet auf der seite und dann zum nächsten gehst
der seite und dann zum nächsten gehst
der seite und dann zum nächsten gehst ist das erste wieder kalt du kriegst es
ist das erste wieder kalt du kriegst es
ist das erste wieder kalt du kriegst es nicht ab was ich damals probiert habe
nicht ab was ich damals probiert habe
nicht ab was ich damals probiert habe ist dabei das war aber ziemlich pepega
ist dabei das war aber ziemlich pepega
ist dabei das war aber ziemlich pepega von mir aber es hat es hat am ende hat
von mir aber es hat es hat am ende hat
von mir aber es hat es hat am ende hat das funktioniert ich habe dann einfach
das funktioniert ich habe dann einfach
das funktioniert ich habe dann einfach mit der heißluft habe ich hier alles
mit der heißluft habe ich hier alles
mit der heißluft habe ich hier alles warm gemacht wieder warm gemacht warm
warm gemacht wieder warm gemacht warm
warm gemacht warm gemacht wieder warm gemacht warm gemacht als es warm war habe
gemacht als es warm war habe
gemacht als es warm war habe ich rausgezogen schnell aber chat wer
ich rausgezogen schnell aber chat wer
ich rausgezogen schnell aber chat wer kann sich denken was dann das problem
kann sich denken was dann das problem
kann sich denken was dann das problem war also es war hier voller lötzinn mit
war so es war hier voller lötzinn mit
war so es war hier voller lötzinn mit einem header drauf und ich habe alles
einem header drauf und ich habe alles
einem header drauf und ich habe alles warm gemacht den header rausgezogen was
warm gemacht den header rausgezogen was
warm gemacht den header rausgezogen was war dann das problem ich werde ich
war dann das problem ich werde ich
war dann das problem ich werde ich jetzt euch auch so das problem war zu
jetzt euch auch so das problem war zu
jetzt euch auch so das problem war zu viel abgeacht soja jaja aus versehenen
viel abgeacht soja jaja aus versehenen
viel abgeacht soja jaja aus versehenen relay von dem adon board habe ich auch
relay von dem adon board habe ich auch
relay von dem adon board habe ich auch abgelötet das wollte ich aber nicht das
abgelötet das wollte ich aber nicht das
abgelötet das wollte ich aber nicht das problem ist dass dann jedoch das ganze
problem ist dass dann jedoch das ganze
problem ist dass dann jedoch das ganze lötzinn drin ist und dann kriegst du ja
lötzinn drin ist und dann kriegst du ja
lötzinn drin ist und dann kriegst du ja nichts mehr rein
nichts mehr rein
nichts mehr rein und dann habe ich es also wieder versucht
und dann habe ich es also wieder versucht
und dann habe ich es also wieder versucht heiß zu machen mit mit dem föhn und es
heiß zu machen mit mit dem föhn und es
heiß zu machen mit mit dem föhn und es auf der anderen seite ganz schnell
auf der anderen seite ganz schnell
auf der anderen seite ganz schnell reinzustecken
reinzustecken
reinzustecken das habe ich auch geschafft und als ich
das habe ich auch geschafft und als ich
das habe ich auch geschafft und als ich dann drin hatte ist mir aufgefallen den
dann drin hatte ist mir aufgefallen den
dann drin hatte ist mir aufgefallen den das war so ein
das war so ein
das war so ein es ist übrigens blödsinn ich habe es ich
es ist übrigens blödsinn ich habe es ich
es ist übrigens blödsinn ich habe es ich habe es gar nicht am raspberry pi
habe es gar nicht am raspberry pi
habe es gar nicht am raspberry pi gelötet ich habe es an dem addon board
gelötet ich habe es an dem addon board
gelötet ich habe es an dem addon board für den raspberry pi gelötet also das
für den raspberry pi gelötet also das
für den raspberry pi gelötet also das was hier dran kommt und dann habe ich
was hier dran kommt und dann habe ich
was hier dran kommt und dann habe ich drauf gehabt dann ist mir aufgefallen
drauf gehabt dann ist mir aufgefallen
drauf gehabt dann ist mir aufgefallen da war so ein kennt ihr kennt ihr noch
da war so ein kennt ihr kennt ihr noch
da war so ein kennt ihr kennt ihr noch die alten stecker von idee kabel ja so
die alten stecker von idee kabel ja so
die alten stecker von idee kabel ja so die alten idee kabel stecker die hier so
die alten idee kabel stecker die hier so
die alten idee kabel stecker die hier so was ist da auch dran gewesen und dann
was ist da auch dran gewesen und dann
was ist da auch dran gewesen und dann habe ich am ende festgestellt nachdem
habe ich am ende festgestellt nachdem
habe ich am ende festgestellt nachdem ich wieder dran hatte dass ich 34
ich wieder dran hatte dass ich 34
ich wieder dran hatte dass ich 34 einschübe verschmolzen habe aus versehen
einschübe verschmolzen habe aus versehen
einschübe verschmolzen habe aus versehen mit dem plastik da konnte ich nicht
mit dem plastik da konnte ich nicht
mit dem plastik da konnte ich nicht mehr richtig benutzen
mehr richtig benutzen
mehr richtig benutzen hey leute ich sage euch das war da habe
hey leute ich sage euch das war da habe
hey leute ich sage euch das war da habe ich richtig verkackt aber gut manchmal
ich richtig verkackt aber gut manchmal
ich richtig verkackt aber gut manchmal wäre eine endlötstation auch praktisch
wäre eine endlötstation auch praktisch
wäre eine endlötstation auch praktisch ich weiß übrigens gar nicht wie eine
ich weiß übrigens gar nicht wie eine
ich weiß übrigens gar nicht wie eine endlötstation aussehen soll
ich weiß übrigens gar nicht wie eine endlötstation aussehen soll es ist einfach nur heißluft ich habe
es ist einfach nur heißluft ich habe
es ist einfach nur heißluft ich habe das nicht gehabt kredit da steht hier
das nicht gehabt kredit da steht hier
das nicht gehabt kredit da steht hier was steht hier neben neben mir
was steht hier neben neben mir
was steht hier neben neben mir angeschlossen am zweiten monitor aber
angeschlossen am zweiten monitor aber
angeschlossen am zweiten monitor aber also ich hatte es jetzt schon eine weile
also ich hatte es jetzt schon eine weile
also ich hatte es jetzt schon eine weile tatsächlich nicht waren ja sehr gute
tatsächlich nicht waren ja sehr gute
tatsächlich nicht waren ja sehr gute idee hat sie lange für den sap das ist
idee hat sie lange für den sap das ist
idee hat sie lange für den sap das ist ja excelente jacks sagen für den sap
ja excelente jacks sagen für den sap
ja excelente jacks sagen für den sap heute geht es ja nicht rund hier ist
heute geht es ja nicht rund hier ist
heute geht es ja nicht rund hier ist irgendwie ab oktober wie ist das wenig
irgendwie ab oktober wie ist das wenig
irgendwie ab oktober wie ist das wenig oktober
oktober
oktober september oder sowas wobei das ja
september oder sowas wobei das ja
september oder sowas wobei das ja eigentlich nicht jetzt ist geht ja sechs
eigentlich nicht jetzt ist geht ja sechs
eigentlich nicht jetzt ist geht ja sechs trailer gesehen ja habe ich habe ich
trailer gesehen ja habe ich habe ich
trailer gesehen ja habe ich habe ich ich muss ja sagen ich bin kein allzu
ich muss ja sagen ich bin kein allzu
ich muss ja sagen ich bin kein allzu großer gta fan also was ich gespielt
großer gta fan also was ich gespielt
großer gta fan also was ich gespielt habe also gekauft gekauft habe ich
habe also gekauft gekauft habe ich
habe also gekauft gekauft habe ich tatsächlich auch gta 5 aber ich habe gta
tatsächlich auch gta 5 aber ich habe gta
tatsächlich auch gta 5 aber ich habe gta 5 nie durchgespielt gar nicht mal
5 nie durchgespielt gar nicht mal
5 nie durchgespielt gar nicht mal wirklich viel gespielt ich geht ja 1 und
wirklich viel gespielt ich geht ja 1 und
wirklich viel gespielt ich geht ja 1 und gta 2 damals habe ich gespielt so 2000
gta 2 damals habe ich gespielt so 2000
gta 2 damals habe ich gespielt so 2000 vor 2000 war das noch und damals war gta
vor 2000 war das noch und damals war gta
vor 2000 war das noch und damals war gta 2 ja so einen killer spiel für für
2 ja so einen killer spiel für für
2 ja so einen killer spiel für für manche wohl sie eigentlich nur aus der
manche wohl sie eigentlich nur aus der
manche wohl sie eigentlich nur aus der vogelperspektive war aber die leute
vogelperspektive war aber die leute
vogelperspektive war aber die leute fanden das nicht so nicht so nice dass
fanden das nicht so nicht so nice dass
fanden das nicht so nicht so nice dass man da zivilisten mit flammenwerfern
man da zivilisten mit flammenwerfern
man da zivilisten mit flammenwerfern abschießt und so na ja zumindest ich
abschießt und so na ja zumindest ich
abschießt und so na ja zumindest ich habe den gta 6 trailer gesehen
habe den gta 6 trailer gesehen
habe den gta 6 trailer gesehen es hat ein bisschen was von bonnie und
es hat ein bisschen was von bonnie und
es hat ein bisschen was von bonnie und kleid gehabt da waren enorm viele ja
kleid gehabt da waren enorm viele ja
kleid gehabt da waren enorm viele ja es wäre aufgefallen auf der anderen
es wäre aufgefallen auf der anderen
es wäre aufgefallen auf der anderen seite es sah halt mal ehrlich aus wie
seite es sah halt mal ehrlich aus wie
seite es sah halt mal ehrlich aus wie wir hatten in gta wenn auch recht gut
wir hatten in gta wenn auch recht gut
wir hatten in gta wenn auch recht gut aussah
aussah
aussah es wird ein voller erfolg werden gab es
es wird ein voller erfolg werden gab es
es wird ein voller erfolg werden gab es in gta was kein voller erfolg war
in gta was kein voller erfolg war
in gta was kein voller erfolg war bisher zumal man muss ja mal sagen okay
bisher zumal man muss ja mal sagen okay
bisher zumal man muss ja mal sagen okay das klingt jetzt so selbstverständlich
das klingt jetzt so selbstverständlich
das klingt jetzt so selbstverständlich ja die haben ja auch immer gut
ja die haben ja auch immer gut
ja die haben ja auch immer gut abgeliefert also nicht wie ich sehe da
abgeliefert also nicht wie ich sehe da
abgeliefert also nicht wie ich sehe da c++ das machen wir jetzt nicht die
c++ das machen wir jetzt nicht die
c++ das machen wir jetzt nicht die idee also die haben ja auch die haben ja
idee also die haben ja auch die haben ja
idee also die haben ja auch die haben ja auch immer gut abgeliefert es gab ja
auch immer gut abgeliefert es gab ja
auch immer gut abgeliefert es gab ja eigentlich kein wirklich schlechtes gta
eigentlich kein wirklich schlechtes gta
eigentlich kein wirklich schlechtes gta wenn man mal den den reviews und
wenn man mal den den reviews und
wenn man mal den den reviews und bewertungen traut ich persönlich kann es
bewertungen traut ich persönlich kann es
bewertungen traut ich persönlich kann es nicht so richtig bewerten weil ich die
nicht so richtig bewerten weil ich die
nicht so richtig bewerten weil ich die meisten gta es gar nicht gespielt habe
meisten gta es gar nicht gespielt habe
meisten gta es gar nicht gespielt habe heute nix steht noch im titel
heute nix steht noch im titel
heute nix steht noch im titel ich mache jetzt package update in
ich mache jetzt package update in
ich mache jetzt package update in meiner linux vm arch by the way
meiner linux vm arch by the way
meiner linux vm arch by the way als das fahrrad noch nicht kaputt war habe
als das fahrrad noch nicht kaputt war habe
als das fahrrad noch nicht kaputt war habe ich mir bei amazon eine lampe zum so
ich mir bei amazon eine lampe zum so
ich mir bei amazon eine lampe zum so anklipsen an den lenker bestellt weil
anklipsen an den lenker bestellt weil
anklipsen an den lenker bestellt weil manchmal will mir auch im dunkeln fahren
manchmal will mir auch im dunkeln fahren
manchmal will mir auch im dunkeln fahren erstens wird man besser gesehen zweiten
erstens wird man besser gesehen zweiten
erstens wird man besser gesehen zweiten sieht man selber was rücklicht habe ich
sieht man selber was rücklicht habe ich
sieht man selber was rücklicht habe ich schon eine weile und die lampe habe ich
schon eine weile und die lampe habe ich
schon eine weile und die lampe habe ich schon bestellt allerdings der shop war
schon bestellt allerdings der shop war
schon bestellt allerdings der shop war fahrrad punkt de und falls das jemand
fahrrad punkt de und falls das jemand
fahrrad punkt de und falls das jemand bekommen hat fahrrad punkt de ist pleite
bekommen hat fahrrad punkt de ist pleite
bekommen hat fahrrad punkt de ist pleite gegangen aber amazon wäre nicht amazon
gegangen aber amazon wäre nicht amazon
gegangen aber amazon wäre nicht amazon war sowas sind wir immer sehr
war sowas sind wir immer sehr
war sowas sind wir immer sehr kundenfreundlich amazon hat mir einfach
kundenfreundlich amazon hat mir einfach
kundenfreundlich amazon hat mir einfach das geld zurück erstattet haben gesagt
das geld zurück erstattet haben gesagt
das geld zurück erstattet haben gesagt wenn sie keine versand bestätigung
wenn sie keine versand bestätigung
wenn sie keine versand bestätigung bekommen vom hersteller oder die vom
bekommen vom hersteller oder die vom
bekommen vom hersteller oder die vom hersteller ist falsch vom versand shop
hersteller ist falsch vom versand shop
hersteller ist falsch vom versand shop dann erstatten sie mir das geld wieder
dann erstatten sie mir das geld wieder
dann erstatten sie mir das geld wieder haben wir das geld zurück erstattet und
haben wir das geld zurück erstattet und
haben wir das geld zurück erstattet und jetzt nach zwei monaten oder so kam
jetzt nach zwei monaten oder so kam
jetzt nach zwei monaten oder so kam vor vorgestern also kam eine lampe an die
vor vorgestern also kam eine lampe an die
vor vorgestern also kam eine lampe an die dich bestellt habe damals und ich
dich bestellt habe damals und ich
dich bestellt habe damals und ich habe das geld schon wieder insofern gab es
habe das geld schon wieder insofern gab es
habe das geld schon wieder insofern gab es eine kostenlose lampe
eine kostenlose lampe
eine kostenlose lampe meine freude hält sich allerdings in
meine freude hält sich allerdings in
meine freude hält sich allerdings in grenzen weil ich hätte mir dann doch
grenzen weil ich hätte mir dann doch
grenzen weil ich hätte mir dann doch die teure lampe bestellen sollen
die teure lampe bestellen sollen
die teure lampe bestellen sollen ich hatte so die auswahl prinzipiell
ich hatte so die auswahl prinzipiell
ich hatte so die auswahl prinzipiell neige ich ja immer dazu richtig
neige ich ja immer dazu richtig
neige ich ja immer dazu richtig richtig gute sachen zu kaufen die auch
gute sachen zu kaufen die auch
gute sachen zu kaufen die auch genau das dementsprechend was ich haben will
genau das dementsprechend was ich haben will
genau das dementsprechend was ich haben will ich habe ein bisschen günstigere lampe
ich habe ein bisschen günstigere lampe
ich habe ein bisschen günstigere lampe gekauft weil ich mir gedacht habe ich war
gekauft weil ich mir gedacht habe ich war
gekauft weil ich mir gedacht habe ich war so selten im dunkel ist nicht so wild
so selten im dunkel ist nicht so wild
so selten im dunkel ist nicht so wild jetzt hätte ich jetzt hätte ich gesagt
jetzt hätte ich jetzt hätte ich gesagt
jetzt hätte ich jetzt hätte ich gesagt er hätte ich mir mal die teure teure
er hätte ich mir mal die teure teure
er hätte ich mir mal die teure teure lampe gekauft wenn die umsonst gewesen
lampe gekauft wenn die umsonst gewesen
lampe gekauft wenn die umsonst gewesen ja jetzt ein guter ich habe gut gucken
ja jetzt ein guter ich habe gut gucken
ja jetzt ein guter ich habe gut gucken was für updates gibt oder gleich zwei
was für updates gibt oder gleich zwei
was für updates gibt oder gleich zwei ich bin was das angeht eigentlich genau
ich bin was das angeht eigentlich genau
ich bin was das angeht eigentlich genau das gegenteil bei mir ist es so ich
das gegenteil bei mir ist es so ich
das gegenteil bei mir ist es so ich kaufe wenig das liegt aber daran weil
kaufe wenig das liegt aber daran weil
kaufe wenig das liegt aber daran weil ich mich tatsächlich für relativ wenig
ich mich tatsächlich für relativ wenig
ich mich tatsächlich für relativ wenig begeistern kann was ich unbedingt haben
begeistern kann was ich unbedingt haben
begeistern kann was ich unbedingt haben will ja da gibt es da gibt es nicht so
will ja da gibt es da gibt es nicht so
will ja da gibt es da gibt es nicht so viel also ich kaufe nicht random
viel also ich kaufe nicht random
viel also ich kaufe nicht random irgendwelche sache war ich bin ja das
irgendwelche sache war ich bin ja das
irgendwelche sache war ich bin ja das könnte ganz cool sein dafür werde ich
könnte ganz cool sein dafür werde ich
könnte ganz cool sein dafür werde ich was kaufe kaufe ich immer was
was kaufe kaufe ich immer was
was kaufe kaufe kaufe ich immer was ordentliches und meistens halt
ordentliches und meistens halt
ordentliches und meistens halt dementsprechend kostet halt was
dementsprechend kostet halt was
dementsprechend kostet halt was ordentliches auch hat man beim fahrrad
ordentliches auch hat man beim fahrrad
ordentliches auch hat man beim fahrrad gesehen hat man beim letzten pc gesehen
gesehen hat man beim letzten pc gesehen
gesehen hat man beim letzten pc gesehen sieht man auch beim ganzen werkzeug was
sieht man auch beim ganzen werkzeug was
sieht man auch beim ganzen werkzeug was ich kaufe und so was ich kaufte immer
ich kaufe und so was ich kaufte immer
ich kaufe und so was ich kaufte immer gescheite sachen der erstens hat man
gescheite sachen der erstens hat man
gescheite sachen der erstens hat man lange länger dran und zweitens macht es
lange länger dran und zweitens macht es
lange länger dran und zweitens macht es auch in der regel mehr spaß damit zu
auch in der regel mehr spaß damit zu
auch in der regel mehr spaß damit zu arbeiten und irgendwie fühlt sich
arbeiten und irgendwie fühlt sich
arbeiten und irgendwie fühlt sich gerade ganz ohne scheiß leute gerade
gerade ganz ohne scheiß leute gerade
gerade ganz ohne scheiß leute gerade ordentliches werkzeug ist halt gibt
ordentliches werkzeug ist halt gibt
ordentliches werkzeug ist halt gibt halt nichts besseres
halt nichts besseres
halt nichts besseres das merke ich immer wieder wenn ich hier
das merke ich immer wieder wenn ich hier
das merke ich immer wieder wenn ich hier meinen schrauben den zusätzlich ich habe
meinen schrauben den zusätzlich ich habe
meinen schrauben den zusätzlich ich habe so ein schraubenzieher mit wie nennt
so ein schraubenzieher mit wie nennt
so ein schraubenzieher mit wie nennt das mit so ratschen funktion hier wirst
das mit so ratschen funktion hier wirst
das mit so ratschen funktion hier wirst ihr hört doch jetzt also hier wie
ihr hört doch jetzt also hier wie
ihr hört doch jetzt also hier wie wie heißt das richtig ein schraubendreher
wie heißt das richtig ein schraubendreher
wie heißt das richtig ein schraubendreher mit ja zum drehen wo man so nach links
mit ja zum drehen wo man so nach links
mit ja zum drehen wo man so nach links und rechts drehen kann oder feststellen
und rechts drehen kann oder feststellen
und rechts drehen kann oder feststellen uns und gerade drin und das ist ein
uns und gerade drin und das ist ein
uns und gerade drin und das ist ein richtig teurer von pb swiss tools aber
richtig teurer von pb swiss tools aber
richtig teurer von pb swiss tools aber der fühlt sich so geil an not got
der fühlt sich so geil an not got
der fühlt sich so geil an not got shivers aber der führt der fühlt sich
shivers aber der führt der fühlt sich so so geil stabil und und nicht
so so geil stabil und und nicht
so so geil stabil und und nicht wackelig und und gut gemacht an
wackelig und und gut gemacht an
wackelig und und gut gemacht an da habe ich immer bock was damit zu
da habe ich immer bock was damit zu
da habe ich immer bock was damit zu machen sobald was anlegt ja zumal das
machen sobald was anlegt ja zumal das
machen sobald was anlegt ja zumal das ist ein ich habe das ja schon mal
ist ein ich habe das ja schon mal
ist ein ich habe das ja schon mal gezeigt sind bei sowas gebe ich immer
gezeigt sind bei sowas gebe ich immer
gezeigt sind bei sowas gebe ich immer gerne geld aus dass ein pb 6510 ich kann
gerne geld aus dass ein pb 6510 ich kann
gerne geld aus dass ein pb 6510 ich kann das aber nicht empfehlen wirklich für
das aber nicht empfehlen wirklich für
das aber nicht empfehlen wirklich für den preis sich diesen krempel zu kaufen
den preis sich diesen krempel zu kaufen
den preis sich diesen krempel zu kaufen aber das ist mein mit abstand lieblings
aber das ist mein mit abstand lieblings
aber das ist mein mit abstand lieblings schraubstelzwerkzeug das ding leider
schraubstelzwerkzeug das ding leider
schraubstelzwerkzeug das ding leider haben immer noch kein darkstream gibt es
haben immer noch kein darkstream gibt es
haben immer noch kein darkstream gibt es gibt abwertungen ja du hast im griff
gibt abwertungen ja du hast im griff
gibt abwertungen ja du hast im griff eingebaut paar bits und hier vorne
eingebaut paar bits und hier vorne
eingebaut paar bits und hier vorne hast du was mit links rechts gerade
hast du was mit links rechts gerade
hast du was mit links rechts gerade feststellen nicht von linus technik
feststellen nicht von linus technik
feststellen nicht von linus technik die ratsche mit funktion linkslauf
die ratsche mit funktion linkslauf
die ratsche mit funktion linkslauf rechtslauf blockierte stellung und das
rechtslauf blockierte stellung und das
rechtslauf blockierte stellung und das hat echt gar keinerlei spielraum also
hat echt gar keinerlei spielraum also
hat echt gar keinerlei spielraum also du merkst nichts wackeln und und es
du merkst nichts wackeln und und es
du merkst nichts wackeln und und es auch super fest in das ist wirklich
auch super fest in das ist wirklich
auch super fest in das ist wirklich liegt auch richtig gut in der hand aber
liegt auch richtig gut in der hand aber
liegt auch richtig gut in der hand aber kann sich ein bisschen streiten manche
kann sich ein bisschen streiten manche
kann sich ein bisschen streiten manche mögen es ja ein bisschen gummi am griff
mögen es ja ein bisschen gummi am griff
mögen es ja ein bisschen gummi am griff zu haben dass es hier nur nur hartes
zu haben dass es hier nur nur hartes
zu haben dass es hier nur nur hartes plastik zwei verschieden ist aber der
plastik zwei verschieden ist aber der
plastik zwei verschieden ist aber der ist gut eine schweizer uhr ich habe
ist gut eine schweizer uhr ich habe
ist gut eine schweizer uhr ich habe überhaupt kein wobei doch ich habe nur
überhaupt kein wobei doch ich habe nur
überhaupt kein wobei doch ich habe nur garmin und garmin fitnesstracker ja
nur garmin und garmin fitnesstracker ja
nur garmin und garmin fitnesstracker ja aber den finde ich den finde ich gut
aber den finde ich den finde ich gut
aber den finde ich den finde ich gut also abobus fahrrad kaputt gibt es was
also abobus fahrrad kaputt gibt es was
also abobus fahrrad kaputt gibt es was neues ja die die versicherung hat gesagt
neues ja die die versicherung hat gesagt
neues ja die die versicherung hat gesagt sie haben keinerlei einspruch gegen
sie haben keinerlei einspruch gegen
sie haben keinerlei einspruch gegen unseren anspruch weil der anwalt hat
unseren anspruch weil der anwalt hat
unseren anspruch weil der anwalt hat dahin geschrieben geld habe ich aber
dahin geschrieben geld habe ich aber
dahin geschrieben geld habe ich aber immer noch nicht wäre ja auch deutlich
immer noch nicht wäre ja auch deutlich
immer noch nicht wäre ja auch deutlich zu einfach wenn das geld einfach schon
zu einfach wenn das geld einfach schon
zu einfach wenn das geld einfach schon da wäre vielleicht brauchen die noch ein
da wäre vielleicht brauchen die noch ein
da wäre vielleicht brauchen die noch ein bisschen dann kaufe ich mir nächstes
bisschen dann kaufe ich mir nächstes
bisschen dann kaufe ich mir nächstes jahr weil lange kann es nicht mehr
jahr weil lange kann es nicht mehr
jahr weil lange kann es nicht mehr dauern erst neues fahrrad wenn es dann
dauern erst neues fahrrad wenn es dann
dauern erst neues fahrrad wenn es dann die neue 1 x 12 elektronische die 2
die neue 1 x 12 elektronische die 2
die neue 1 x 12 elektronische die 2 schalt die i2 wie auch immer das
schalt die i2 wie auch immer das
schalt die i2 wie auch immer das ausspricht schaltung gibt ich hatte jetzt
ausspricht schaltung gibt ich hatte jetzt
ausspricht schaltung gibt ich hatte jetzt aktuell hatte ich ja 1 x 12
aktuell hatte ich ja 1 x 12
aktuell hatte ich ja 1 x 12 elektronisch und sobald es 1 x 12
elektronisch und sobald es 1 x 12
elektronisch und sobald es 1 x 12 elektronisch gibt dann also gibt es ja
elektronisch gibt dann also gibt es ja
elektronisch gibt dann also gibt es ja von von sram gibt es die aber ja 1 x 12
von von sram gibt es die aber ja 1 x 12
von von sram gibt es die aber ja 1 x 12 fast noch besser wenn so ein bisschen
fast noch besser wenn so ein bisschen
fast noch besser wenn so ein bisschen dauert bis die kohle ist ich meine ich
dauert bis die kohle ist ich meine ich
dauert bis die kohle ist ich meine ich einmal zwölf wäre besser ich meine
einmal zwölf wäre besser ich meine
einmal zwölf wäre besser ich meine einmal 12 wäre mir lieber als einmal 11
einmal 12 wäre mir lieber als einmal 11
einmal 12 wäre mir lieber als einmal 11 nicht zwölf also ich hatte ich hatte
nicht zwölf also ich hatte ich hatte
nicht zwölf also ich hatte ich hatte 1 x 12 die 2 und ich hätte gerne einmal
1 x 12 die 2 und ich hätte gerne einmal
1 x 12 die 2 und ich hätte gerne einmal 1 x 11 die 2 hatte ich und ich hätte
1 x 11 die 2 hatte ich und ich hätte
1 x 11 die 2 hatte ich und ich hätte gern 1 x 12 die 2 wenn das nächstes jahr
gern 1 x 12 die 2 wenn das nächstes jahr
gern 1 x 12 die 2 wenn das nächstes jahr rauskommt aber ja luftig ist ich habe
rauskommt aber ja luftig ist ich habe
rauskommt aber ja luftig ist ich habe kamel gelesen aber karamell kühlschwein
kamel gelesen aber karamell kühlschwein
kamel gelesen aber karamell kühlschwein ja man fahren wurde zerstört allerdings
ja man fahren wurde zerstört allerdings
ja man fahren wurde zerstört allerdings zerstört in anführungszeichen also das
zerstört in anführungszeichen also das
zerstört in anführungszeichen also das ist schon noch in einem stück aber hat
ist schon noch in einem stück aber hat
ist schon noch in einem stück aber hat laut gutachter noch 80 euro restwert
laut gutachter noch 80 euro restwert
laut gutachter noch 80 euro restwert weil mich auf dem fahrradweg eine
weil mich auf dem fahrradweg eine
weil mich auf dem fahrradweg eine umgefahren hat im auto
umgefahren hat im auto
umgefahren hat im auto ich hatte komplett vorfahrt und alles
ich hatte komplett vorfahrt und alles
ich hatte komplett vorfahrt und alles ich hab mich umgefahren und nachdem es
ich hab mich umgefahren und nachdem es
ich hab mich umgefahren und nachdem es ein karbon rahmen war vom fahrrad kann
ein karbon rahmen war vom fahrrad kann
ein karbon rahmen war vom fahrrad kann es halt durchaus sein dass der risse
es halt durchaus sein dass der risse
es halt durchaus sein dass der risse hat deswegen kann ich mit dem nicht mehr
hat deswegen kann ich mit dem nicht mehr
hat deswegen kann ich mit dem nicht mehr auf der fahrrad fahren er auf der
auf der fahrrad fahren er auf der
auf der fahrrad fahren er auf der fahrbahn fahren oder auf der straße
fahrbahn fahren oder auf der straße
fahrbahn fahren oder auf der straße fahren oder draußen ich kann mit dem
fahren oder draußen ich kann mit dem
fahren oder draußen ich kann mit dem fahrrad nicht mehr draußen fahren so
fahrrad nicht mehr draußen fahren so
fahrrad nicht mehr draußen fahren so muss man es eigentlich sagen und jetzt
muss man es eigentlich sagen und jetzt
muss man es eigentlich sagen und jetzt habe ich hier auf so einem indoor
habe ich hier auf so einem indoor
habe ich hier auf so einem indoor trainer stehen und dann habe ich
trainer stehen und dann habe ich
trainer stehen und dann habe ich vielleicht demnächst zwei wenn die
vielleicht demnächst zwei wenn die
vielleicht demnächst zwei wenn die versicherung mal bezahlt da kaufe ich
versicherung mal bezahlt da kaufe ich
versicherung mal bezahlt da kaufe ich mir eins für draußen und das andere
mir eins für draußen und das andere
mir eins für draußen und das andere lasse ich auf dem indoor trainer stehen
lasse ich auf dem indoor trainer stehen
lasse ich auf dem indoor trainer stehen das hat aber noch sonst noch machen ja
das hat aber noch sonst noch machen ja
das hat aber noch sonst noch machen ja also der am lenker ist neben was kaputt
also der am lenker ist neben was kaputt
also der am lenker ist neben was kaputt am pedal ist was kaputt die schaltung
am pedal ist was kaputt die schaltung
am pedal ist was kaputt die schaltung war komplett verbogen wobei die schaltung
war komplett verbogen wobei die schaltung
war komplett verbogen wobei die schaltung habe ich selbst gefixt ich habe mir bei
habe ich selbst gefixt ich habe mir bei
habe ich selbst gefixt ich habe mir bei rose ein neues schalt auge gekauft für
rose ein neues schalt auge gekauft für
rose ein neues schalt auge gekauft für zehn euro habe das ausgetauscht jetzt
zehn euro habe das ausgetauscht jetzt
zehn euro habe das ausgetauscht jetzt geht die schaltung wieder halbwegs
geht die schaltung wieder halbwegs
geht die schaltung wieder halbwegs ja jetzt habe ich doch so ein smart
ja jetzt habe ich doch so ein smart
ja jetzt habe ich doch so ein smart trainer daheim stehen oder habe ich
trainer daheim stehen oder habe ich
trainer daheim stehen oder habe ich vielleicht eine eine positive sache von
vielleicht eine eine positive sache von
vielleicht eine eine positive sache von umgefahren werden auf ein fahrradweg habe
umgefahren werden auf ein fahrradweg habe
umgefahren werden auf ein fahrradweg habe ich dann nämlich vielleicht habe ich
ich dann nämlich vielleicht habe ich
ich dann nämlich vielleicht habe ich dann ein fahrrad für den heimtrainer und
dann ein fahrrad für den heimtrainer und
dann ein fahrrad für den heimtrainer und ein fahrrad für draußen
ein fahrrad für draußen
ein fahrrad für draußen mir ist naja nichts passiert kann man
mir ist naja nichts passiert kann man
mir ist naja nichts passiert kann man nichts sagen mir ist nicht viel passiert
nichts sagen mir ist nicht viel passiert
nichts sagen mir ist nicht viel passiert ich hatte ein bisschen abschürfung am
ich hatte ein bisschen abschürfung am
ich hatte ein bisschen abschürfung am arm am bein mir hat die hüftknochen auf
arm am bein mir hat die hüftknochen auf
arm am bein mir hat die hüftknochen auf der seite wo ich halt auf der motorhaube
der seite wo ich halt auf der motorhaube
der seite wo ich halt auf der motorhaube gelandet bin für für so 34 tage weh
gelandet bin für für so 34 tage weh
gelandet bin für für so 34 tage weh getan ich habe ein bisschen kopf wird
getan ich habe ein bisschen kopf wird
getan ich habe ein bisschen kopf wird zwei drei tage aber nicht wirklich viel
zwei drei tage aber nicht wirklich viel
zwei drei tage aber nicht wirklich viel also es hielt sich in grenzen
also es hielt sich in grenzen
also es hielt sich in grenzen man muss aber echt dazu sagen man merkt
man muss aber echt dazu sagen man merkt
man muss aber echt dazu sagen man merkt dass erst später also die hat mich
dass erst später also die hat mich
dass erst später also die hat mich umgefahren und ich dachte mir so ja gut
umgefahren und ich dachte mir so ja gut
umgefahren und ich dachte mir so ja gut ist ja gerade noch mal gerade noch mal
ist ja gerade noch mal gerade noch mal
ist ja gerade noch mal gerade noch mal gut gegangen
gut gegangen
gut gegangen da habe ich dann habe halt fotos
da habe ich dann habe halt fotos
da habe ich dann habe halt fotos gemacht alles dann bin ich wieder aufs
gemacht alles dann bin ich wieder aufs
gemacht alles dann bin ich wieder aufs fahrrad gestiegen und heim gefahren
fahrrad gestiegen und heim gefahren
fahrrad gestiegen und heim gestiegen und heim gestiegen und heim gestiegen und da hat mir noch nichts
gestiegen und heim gestiegen und heim gestiegen und heim gestiegen und da hat mir noch nichts
gestiegen und heim gestiegen und heim gestiegen und heim gestiegen und da hat mir noch nichts großartig wehgetan ich habe es ein
großartig wehgetan ich habe es ein
großartig wehgetan ich habe es ein bisschen ich habe es ein bisschen so am
bisschen ich habe es ein bisschen so am
bisschen ich habe es ein bisschen so am abend gemerkt und damit nicht
abend gemerkt und damit nicht
abend gemerkt und damit nicht großartig was wir getan aber abends habe
großartig was wir getan aber abends habe
großartig was wir getan aber abends habe ich dann gemerkt ja da habe ich
ich dann gemerkt ja da habe ich
ich dann gemerkt ja da habe ich dann gemerkt ja da habe ich dann gemerkt ja da habe ich dann gemerkt ja da habe ich dann gemerkt ja da habe ich dann gemerkt ja da habe ich dann gemerkt ja da habe ich dann gemerkt ja da habe ich dann gemerkt ja da habe ich dann gemerkt ja da habe ich dann gemerkt ja da habe ich dann gemerkt ja da habe ich dann gemerkt ja da habe ich dann gemerkt ja da habe ich dann gemerkt ja da habe ich dann gemerkt ja da habe ich dann gemerkt ja da habe ich dann gemerkt ja da habe ich dann gemerkt ja da habe ich dann gemerkt ja da habe ich dann gemerkt ja da habe ich dann gemerkt ja da habe ich dann gemerkt ja da habe ich dann gemerkt ja da habe ich dann gemerkt ja da habe ich dann gemerkt ja da habe ich dann gemerkt ja da habe ich dann gemerkt ja da habe ich dann gemerkt ja da habe ich dann gemerkt ja da habe ich dann gemerkt ja da habe ich dann gemerkt
ja da habe ich dann gemerkt ja da habe ich dann gemerkt ja da habe ich dann gemerkt ja da habe ich dann gemerkt ja da habe ich dann gemerkt ja da habe ich dann gemerkt ja da habe ich dann gemerkt ja da habe ich dann gemerkt ja da habe ich dann gemerkt ja da habe ich dann gemerkt ja da habe ich dann gemerkt ja da habe ich dann gemerkt ja da habe ich dann gemerkt ja da habe ich dann gemerkt ja da habe ich dann gemerkt ja da habe ich dann gemerkt ja da habe ich dann gemerkt ja da habe ich dann gemerkt ja da habe ich dann gemerkt ja da habe ich dann gemerkt ja da habe ich dann gemerkt ja da habe ich dann gemerkt ja da habe ich dann gemerkt ja da habe ich dann gemerkt ja da habe ich dann gemerkt ja da habe ich dann gemerkt ja da habe ich dann gemerkt ja da habe ich dann gemerkt ja da habe ich dann gemerkt ja da habe ich dann gemerkt ja da habe ich dann gemerkt ja da habe ich
Ich habe gleich gemerkt, mir fehlt nichts irgendwie, ja.
Ich konnte ohne Probleme aufstehen und ich habe auch so rum, so die Hände mir angeguckt und gesagt, ist eigentlich, fehlt nichts, alles gut.
Dann bin ich aufgestanden und als ich aufgestanden bin und einfach nur gestanden habe, ja, habe ich gemerkt, dass voll meine Beine zittern.
Also so leichtes Adrenalin-Kick hatte man dann da doch, ja.
Also nicht viel, aber, also es ist nicht so, dass ich irgendwie halb umgefallen wäre oder so, aber ich habe gestanden und ich habe ungefähr ein bisschen so gezittert, wie wenn es kalt ist, aber nur an den Beinen, nur an den Beinen.
Machst du auch Advent of Code on Stream?
Haben wir gestern gemacht, gestern, gestern haben wir den ersten Tag Aufgabe 1 und 2 gemacht.
Schon witzig.
Schon wieder?
Nö, jetzt lag nichts mehr.
No lag.
So.
Radiosignal sagt, ich habe bei der Arbeit relativ viele regelmäßige Aufträge, die ich abarbeiten muss.
Ich brauche irgendwas, um die Aufträge bzw. Schritte zu dokumentieren, abhaken und die Termine zu verhalten.
Kann jemand was?
Das klingt ein bisschen wie ein Ticketsystem, oder?
Wobei es wahrscheinlich hier nicht um Softwareentwicklung geht.
Pauschal würde ich auch sagen, im Zweifelsfall, irgendeine Jira-Installation, die kostet ja noch nicht mal was bis 10, bis 10 Benutzer.
Aber auf der anderen Seite ist das wahrscheinlich fast schon ein bisschen Overkill für dich, ein Jira zu installieren.
Macht euer eigenes Ticketsystem aus.
Selbst was programmieren wäre doch richtig bescheuert.
Oder du meinst selbst was installieren.
Ja, ich kann dir nichts empfehlen.
Ich habe die letzten Jahre fast ausschließlich mit Jira gearbeitet.
Alternativen, die ich gesehen habe, sind auf jeden Fall nicht.
Also ich kenne noch zwei andere Ticketsysteme, mit denen ich in letzter Zeit was zu tun hatte.
Das eine heißt, glaube ich, gibt es sowas wie ServiceNow Ticketsystem?
Ja, irgendwie sowas.
Super, super, over-engineertes, over-engineertes Ding.
Guck mal, wenn die Werbung für Ticketsystem machen, wenn die Werbung für Ticketsystem machen und nicht mal, ja.
Das ist das, glaube ich.
Ja, ja, ja, ja.
Das sieht, genauso hässlich sieht das aus, richtig.
Ja, ganz eklig.
So, das ist Schrott.
Das willst du nicht verwenden.
Und das andere, was ich noch kennengelernt habe die letzten Jahre, ist Helpline.
Hatte damit vielleicht irgendjemand von euch mal die Ehre?
Helpline?
Helpline gibt es nicht mehr.
Helpline heißt jetzt ServiceWare Processes.
Helpline, du kennst das?
Das ist Megascheiße, oder?
Das ist der...